[Music]
hi hi how you doing i'm doing well
i had such a blast watching this season
and your character is just
so much fun
when this roll
came your way how much did they tell you
about her were you familiar with the
show like did you
get the scripts to read was it just
conversations like did you know what you
would get into for two episodes
good question um
i was not familiar with the show
i got the scripts before i watched any
of the episodes and i i think as i
after i read the first script
uh episode 7
you know i was so taken with the
dialogue and it was so clear
what the the level of humor was in the
world that they were living in i think i
laughed so many times out loud and then
i watched the first season and um and
it's just you know that that type of
irreverence is so right up my alley and
um it's it's delightful to watch and
and it was a lot of fun to get to be
able to say yes i want to jump into this
world because
it really appeals to me and um
yeah that's how it happened
there's something so fun about watching
people be naughty in this incredible
wardrobe i don't know what it is it's
just something so delightful about that
i i understand yeah
it seems like this wardrobe is
very extra i mean there is a lot that
goes into it what was it like to get
fitted for to wear to work in these
incredible costumes how much does that
inform the character
um
quite a lot i mean that you know as you
would imagine many
fittings um
quite a process
um
but a fun process to be involved in and
uh
and to watch
them coming together um and little bits
added and tucks happening and different
layers happening and um
and then of course there's the panniers
which are the things that you wear on
top of the corset in order to make the
hips
that white and
there's something so comical about
those that address with panniers anyway
that
just the fact that what is wearing a
dress that looks like that immediately
makes you feel like you're in a comedy
or should be in a comedy and it affects
everything it affects how you move how
you go through doorways how you sit how
you you know
and it's um
it's a lot of weight on one's hips um
[Music]
i wasn't expecting
that so much but it was
uh you know such a a pleasure to get to
wear these kind of masterpieces on a
daily basis that uh you kind of forget
that and
how did you view this woman and how did
you view her relationship with catherine
do you feel like she loves catherine
[Laughter]
um
yes i think she does i think she does
love catherine and
i think that um
she just
has a plan
and to her her plan is the right way and
it's the way that she has gotten
a lot of attention herself but it's also
a way that um she thinks is
the best way for her daughters and
she doesn't want that to be
altered or messed with and so
she basically will do
whatever it takes it turns out in order
to
have the outcome that she
wants to have and so
you can still be
that manipulative
and yet
love i think
what does it like to do the slapping
scene there seems to be quite a slapping
theme this season i mean captain clapped
herself several times
there there's quite a lot of slapping
going on
so what goes into doing that i mean is
there a conversation is there rehearsal
how many times do you have to do that
well it's all down to
uh the angle that is being shot
so what you hope
is that you're actually not going to
make contact
because where the camera is
is
my hand does not make contact with
elle's head
but her head turns at the moment my hand
is coming across it and
the sound is added later
and so
one hopes that that's how it goes
i have had to punch somebody once
where i did make contact and that is not
fun both
for them or for
your hand because it's yeah so
it really needs professionals to be
around to uh kind of show you how to do
it properly and
and there were they were professionals
you've gone from playing margaret
thatcher in the crown to catherine the
great's mother in the grapes to now
eleanor roosevelt and the first lady
has one of those been more challenging
than the others do they each present
their own challenges i mean is it easier
like to figure out a character when you
have
little to no information and can do your
own background or is it easier when you
have all of this history to refer to
well there's actually not that much
history on joanna and so i'm not sure
whether i would necessarily count her in
that triptych
certainly both for
thatcher and for eleanor
there was so
much uh that it was you know it was
almost an embarrassment of riches and uh
and for
i i'd say honestly that probably eleanor
was the hardest um
there was just there was something about
her and
you know it's a i mean it was this
i i don't know why it was i found it
more of a challenge than
with that i mean certainly it was more
episodes
it it was
a
longer time frame between beginning and
end it covered
more time she aged
[Music]
uh
more history
um
and also there's
so many different
sides to her you know with thatcher you
only really see her
a little bit of as a mother and wife
but mostly as a politician and
with um eleanor you get to see a a
well-rounded um perspective of of
who this woman was
you know over a couple decades of her
lifetime and so
i think that was probably part of the
part of the challenge
what was it like to embody her and to
make those discoveries and to have that
little roosevelt family to work with oh
my god heaven i mean
really heaven because she's such an
extraordinary woman i mean she was such
a
a powerhouse of a woman and i i learned
so much uh i didn't realize it was
so much that i didn't know
and um
and
i just there's
it's a treasure trove of information
that's out there about them and the
degree to which they
her and franklin had impact on
uh you know on the citizens of
america but also
around the world and um
and the works that she did and where she
funneled her personal finances and the
books that she wrote and the
causes that she you know attached
herself to
from the very beginning to the very end
she just she didn't rest and
she was just of service and
she was extraordinary it was amazing to
be able to be in her shoes for a little
while
yeah i mean you've been playing these
extraordinary women and they've been so
fascinating to watch i mean just i loved
the scenes between you and elle fanning
she embodies her role so brilliantly
what did you enjoy about working with
her as a scene partner
she's fantastic she's so you know she's
so committed to this character and she's
so
good and so specific and and
fascinating to watch her work and
just a joy
to work with and and and
you know and so was nick and everyone
was they they made me feel very
welcome and um they're having so much
fun and they make it fun for you too and
uh
um
it was a real pleasure
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it it seems like a delightfully
fun world to live in for a little bit
i appreciate you talking to me about it
it was so much fun to watch no thank you